y hoy jueves tenemos una sección
especial de revista de prensa ya le
decimos por qué porque desde que rusia
empezó a la invasión a ucrania parte de
la atención se ha centrado en la batalla
por el relato y en el centro de la
polémica los medios estatales rusos rt y
sputnik que han sido bloqueados de la
unión europea y calificados por la
presidenta de la comisión gustaria poner
ley en propaganda mediática del kremlin
para ello por supuesto está
acompañándome en esta sección especial
de revista de prensa la titular rosa
pérez más de borrosa que van a estar
contigo buenos dias raúl en primer lugar
agradecer a nuestros compañeros herminia
fernández y santiago lópez por habernos
ayudado también a preparar este especial
y como comentaba en el centro de la
polémica
rt y sputnik estos medios estatales
rusos y hemos y es que hemos sido
testigos no de distintos periodistas en
activo en estas cadenas de televisión
que denuncian ser acosados o incluso
amenazados en redes sociales por otro
lado también hemos leído en la prensa y
también en las redes sociales que
distintos profesionales de ésta las
televisiones están decidiendo dejar a
sus empleos por estar precisamente en
desacuerdo con las líneas editoriales y
para conversar de todo ello raúl nos
acompaña como decías en esta sección
especial yo ni ti con él es periodista y
durante los últimos dos años trabajo en
moscú en la cadena inglesa de rt hasta
que hace unos días decidió dejar su
trabajo buenos días johnny muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros thank you
very much for being erguidas no sé dónde
lo estamos viendo ahorita nos vamos a
rosa pero puedes incluso ya puedes
comenzar a preguntarle pues lo que
nosotros necesitamos saber y yo ni
queríamos empezar
preguntándole por qué decidió dejar su
trabajo en rt
yo renuncie por la guerra no renuncie en
protesta yo estaba feliz trabajando en
el arte y estaba trabajando para mejorar
y profesionalizar la organización pero
el día que russian perdió de civil que
no podía trabajar más para una
organización
patrocinada por el medio ruso por el
gobierno ruso
jon y un gusto saludarlo usted en este
momento se encuentra en turquía usted
porque se encuentra en ese territorio
fue porque renuncié estabas trabajando
para rt y tenía una visa laboral rusa
cuando renuncie ellos cancelaron mi visa
y debido a todos los problemas con los
vuelos a través de unión europea ya no
hay muchos vuelos que pasan por rossi en
estos momentos que
pasan por estambul pasan por dwight por
armenia la mayoría de personas está
viniendo estambul
aquí en estambul hay muchos periodistas
rusos
y mucha experiencia es extranjero es que
solían vivir moscú
johnny para volver a lo que fue su etapa
en rt a lo largo de estos dos años
entiendo como decía que estaba
felizmente desarrollando su profesión
entonces en ningún momento anterior se
había planteado dejarlo fue por algo que
cambió con la guerra como decía usted
consideró que no podía seguir trabajando
por un medio que estaba financiado por
el estado ruso pero digamos nos ha
llegado información de que se dio la
directiva de no referirse a lo que pasa
en ucrania como invasión o como guerra
sino como operación especial que otras
órdenes tenía y éstas pues directivas
tan claras a la hora de cubrir la
situación bélica en ucrania no
influyeron en su decisión de dejar el
trabajo
yo renuncié el día de la ecuación
entonces antes de eso teníamos ninguna
instrucción estábamos cubriendo todo de
manera correcta pero cuando el kremlin
decía que había que reportarlo cuando lo
consciente decía que va a reportar lo
cual sea la inteligencia que hubiera del
occidente
ninguna nosotros pensó que la guerra
llegaría cuando apareció fue una
sorpresa para todos nuestros presa para
todos en organizaciones
yo renuncie antes de tener la
oportunidad de recibir una directiva
sobre decir esto aquellos pibes
realmente nunca experimenté esa
situación en el que porque renuncié el
día 1 johnny también sabemos de varios
brazos de periodistas en este contexto
de guerra que han dejado trabajar en
este o sputnik se trata de casos
aislados o hay un número considerable de
periodistas que debido a estas
directrices ya lo que está ocurriendo y
no están de acuerdo han dejado sus
puestos de trabajo
muchas personas han renunciado
yo conozco más de 10 personas
que dejaron nada más la redacción en
inglés
y sé que en otras partes del gobierno en
otras para otra empresa como el español
en árabe en alemán
y todas las partes de la compañía han
visto personas infelices con lo que está
sucediendo
en general están en contra de la guerra
en contra de ucrania
claro porque usted comentaba que usted
se fue antes de tener la oportunidad de
recibir ninguna directiva pero usted
debe tener compañeros que le podrán
contar cómo es la situación y el
ambiente ahí mismo si hay como dice un
malestar porque hay compañeros suyos que
están en desacuerdo con la guerra hasta
qué punto este malestar llega a las
jerarquías o hay también malestar entre
las jerarquías de la cadena
si definitivamente hay incomodidad de la
compañía pero lo cierto es que la culpa
no tiene que ver con los editores dentro
de la compañía
viene de una ley una nueva ley que fue
probada rusia
dos periodos podrían recibir 15 años en
cárcel se reportan de manera errada
mucha gente en rusia está asustada de
decir lo que no debe decir
y
muchos de los problemas no vienen de rt
como tal
sino el sistema legal de fusión
ahora qué opina de las palabras de la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der layen que definió el sputnik
como una maquinaria mediática al kremlin
y que justifican con mentiras la guerra
iniciada por rusia justifican así su
invasión
a ucrania está de acuerdo con esto
cuando estaba trabajando ahí nunca sentí
que hiciera parte de una maquinaria de
propaganda entiendo por qué dirían eso
ahora
por estas leyes tan serias sobre los
medios de moscú
por supuesto hay experiencias que
trabajan para repetir y viven en moscú
tienen que seguir leyes muy estrictas yo
entiendo
por qué dirían eso ahora pero antes
yo no sentía nada distinto muchos
jóvenes ambiciosos tratando de hacer el
mejor trabajo todos los días
por supuesto es imposible hacerlo ahora
en la situación actual
pero entonces usted está de acuerdo con
esta prohibición y considera que puede
servir para algo
yo entiendo las razones por las cuales
se te está vetado pero
es complicado no mucha gente alrededor
del mundo verte
vetando sujetarlo no tiene mucho efecto
sin embargo las consecuencias pueden ser
gigantes
la gente se está perdiendo acceso a los
medios extranjeros como bbc y otros y
eso puede ser bastante serio
el panorama de los medios entusiastas
además de restringidos la gente rusa
pierde acceso a medios valencianos
y remover este tipo de medio solamente
puede hacer que la propaganda afecte
mucho más de la gente y sea mucho más
convincente o sea considera que el hecho
de que se esté restringiendo el acceso a
la información en rusia como usted
comentaba pues con el cese de
operaciones de distintos medios
extranjeros tiene que ver con que
previamente la unión europea haya pues
vetado a rt ya sputnik
y
si lo que sea que la unión europea está
haciendo lo que sea que las naciones
unidas haga rusia lo va a copiar y lo va
hacer más extremo
en los medios estatales rusos son
vetados en otros países existen
medianamente van a bloquear a los medios
de esos países en media en rusia es
bastante simple
yo ni quiero preguntarle si usted siente
algún tipo de miedo o veto o a la hora
de buscar un nuevo trabajo luego de
haber trabajado en 'russia today' en
todo este contexto de guerra no sé si a
lo mejor ha conversado con colegas o con
otros directivos de otro medio de
comunicación siente que su trabajo de
informar y trabajar para otra cadena de
comunicación puede estar en peligro
por supuesto pensado en esto
pero estaba en comunicación con los dos
corresponsales de moscú
desde distintos de distintos países del
reino unido eeuu
muchos de ellos estaban contentos con mi
esposo los personales el cuento es que
muchas personas en rt son trabajadores
excelentes
pero están marcados por la marca ret
si una persona rt dice algo
algo un poco usado todos somos
bautizados de la misma manera
personalmente estoy feliz con lo que se
considera de mí pero sé que otros pueden
no estarlo y usted es digamos consciente
le ha llegado por parte de sus
compañeros que siguen en activo en rt
pues que estén recibiendo amenazas o
acoso en las redes sociales
no he escuchado de ellos
la mayoría de los rostros más conocidos
han dejado el canal
la gente que se queda ahí es gente no
muy conocimiento se siente que su
reputación está en peligro
y para terminar para usted supuso un
dilema entre pues sus convicciones
personales y lo que era pues su trabajo
su sustento de vida tomar esta decisión
de dejar rt
no realmente
antes del inicio de la guerra no tuve
problemas trabajando para el reto pensé
que tenía un buen trabajo que estaba
escribiendo historias balanceadas apenas
la guerra ocurrió no
entendí que no podía seguir trabajando
ahí con mi moral y con mi conciencia
y john y nosotros queríamos contar aquí
con alguien de rt para que nos aportará
también su punto de vista sobre todo lo
que hemos estado conversando sin embargo
nadie ha querido participar en este
espacio a que cree que se debe
esta voluntad de no hacer comentarios
creo que se debe a que muchas personas
en rusia
sienten que los medios occidentales
están en contra de ellos
una guerra no ocurre solamente en el
terreno sino de la información
estoy seguro que algunas personas que
quisieran hablar pero la persona
promedia que trabaja para la compañía no
quiere hablar y
siente que podría decir cosas
equivocadas que podrían meterse en
problemas si
esa sería mi teoría pues yo ni gracias a
por su tiempo por acceder a nuestro
pedido y hablar con nosotros conversar
sobre esta situación que ocurre en rt en
este contexto de guerra yo ni gracias un
abrazo desde la ciudad de bogotá y parte
de todo el equipo de directo américa de
france 24
un abrazo yo ni rosa precisamente leamos
entonces el comunicado que él recibió de
parte de la comunicación de prensa de rt
efectivamente porque como decíamos antes
si quiera que les propusiéramos una
fecha nos dijeron textualmente que
desafortunadamente nadie de rt estará
disponible para una entrevista y
adjuntaron un comunicado en nombre de
anabel quina redactora jefa adjunta de
rt que dice lo siguiente que el mundo
occidental no respeta la libertad de
expresión y no considera válida otra
opinión que no sea la propia está claro
desde hace mucho tiempo durante años se
nos ha repetido que los reguladores
europeos son independientes de la
política ahora se muestran sin máscaras
la unión europea abiertamente prohíbe rt
en europa obligan a los operadores de
radiodifusión a dejar de emitir nuestro
canal revocar su licencia sin motivo
alguno en los últimos días hemos
escuchado muchas declaraciones de parte
de la clase dirigente de occidente sobre
la necesidad de cerrar rt pero ni la
jefa de la comisión europea ni el primer
ministro del reino y nadie más ha
aportado ni una sola evidencia de que r
te haya incumplido las normas de emisión
ni tampoco un solo ejemplo de
desinformación por parte de rtp nos
prohíben que trabajemos por una razón
ahora en occidente cualquier punto de
vista que difiera del oficial
simplemente no tiene derecho a existir
esa fue la parte entonces de rte rosa
gracias por esta revisa esta revista de
prensa especial insistimos y raúl que
nosotros aquí sí que queríamos que
compartieran su punto de vista no raúl y
este espacio siempre va estar abierto
para cuando ellos quieran graciasrosa
ustedes continúa con nosotros seguimos
con más de directo
[Música]